today i'm pleased to announce
nominations and staff for
critical foreign policy national
security positions key nominations
and appointments for the critical
economic positions i'm really pleased to
add members
to my team that'll get the job done it's
a rule of thumb in washington that
personnel is policy
that is to say a new president's choices
for top jobs in his administration
tell you an awful lot about where that
administration will be headed
we've now seen president-elect joe biden
make more than two dozen choices for top
jobs in the administration that will
take office in january
and that's enough to draw some
conclusions about the kind of team he's
put together
the first thing to say perhaps is that
mr biden clearly chose not to let the
dispute about the outcome of the 2020
election those lawsuits president trump
and his campaign
have filed to try to overturn the
results from getting in the way of
moving forward
on the personnel front you know under
similar circumstances in 2000 when the
outcome of the election again was under
dispute
the new president then george w bush
chose not to make choices for top jobs
until december
and some people think that put his new
administration behind the curve a little
bit at the outset
that's clearly a risk mr biden chose not
to take beyond that there are several
notable characteristics that mark the
emerging biden team
first it's center left not far left joe
biden campaigned and won
as a centrist democrat and against the
more progressive wing of his own party
and his team reflects that there's no
senator bernie sanders
there's no senator elizabeth warren
they're the favorites of democratic
progressives
instead mr biden has tended more toward
fellow veterans of the obama
administration
people with establishment credentials
and people who have worked with mr biden
for years
including his chief of staff ron clain
his national security adviser jake
sullivan
his white house counselor steve roshetti
his secretary of state tony blinken
and the latest addition to that list and
the surprising one susan rice who's
moved from being a national security
expert
to head of the domestic policy council
second this is not exactly a team of
rivals you know when barack obama won
the presidency in 2008
he famously picked his top democratic
primary opponent that year hillary
clinton
to be his secretary of state arguably
the most important person in his cabinet
i have known hillary clinton as a friend
a colleague
a source of counsel and a tough
campaign opponent she possesses an
extraordinary intelligence
and a remarkable work ethic i am proud
that she will be our next secretary of
state
well that hasn't been so much the
pattern here joe biden obviously picked
kamala harris a primary season opponent
to be his running mate
and he's just chosen pete buda judge the
former mayor of south bend indiana
and another opponent in the primaries to
be secretary of transportation
but most of the top jobs have instead
gone to people who joe biden has known
for years in other capacities such as
general lloyd austin
who was the leader of troops in iraq
when joe biden was vice president they
got to know each other then
he's picked to be now secretary of
defense third this team is diverse
mr biden said during the campaign and
repeatedly sensed the election that he
wants to pick a team that looks like
america
and his choices clearly reflect a desire
to do that
i said at the outset i wanted to
represent this campaign to represent and
look
like america we've done that now that's
what the administration will look like
and act like for all those of you
some firsts have been set here the white
house communications team will be made
up of all women
the treasury secretary will be a woman
her deputy will be a black man
the former head of the congressional
black caucus will be a top white house
advisor
the director of national intelligence
will be a woman for the first time
some on the left will say there should
have been more diversity but some
critics will say there
has been some diversity for diversity's
sake and they'll probably point to
general austin at the pentagon
or california attorney general javier
basara at the department of health and
human services despite the fact
he doesn't have a health or a medical
background fourth most of these picks
will not be controversial but a few may
be
it's rare for a new president not to get
the senate to go along with his top
choices to fill out his new
administration but it's not unheard of
the most notable exception in recent
times probably came in 1988
when the new president george h.w bush
picked a former senator john tower to be
a secretary of defense
and the senate rejected that pick i will
be recorded as the first cabinet nominee
in the history of the republic to be
rejected in the first 90 days of a
presidency
and perhaps be harshly judged if
republicans control the senate after
a couple of runoff races in georgia in
january
they'll be in a position to block
president-elect biden's picks if they
choose to do so and they may make
one or two choices to make that point
clear
one of the people who's a perhaps
vulnerable in that regard is near a
tandem
pick to head the office of management
and budget and who's riled up republican
senators with some of her partisan
comments over the years
as he finishes out his team it'll be
interesting to see whether mr biden goes
for a couple of republicans for offices
just to make real his pledge that he
wants to work across the aisle with the
other party
bottom line is that this team as is
often the case reflects the president
that has chosen it that is to say
it's long on washington experience and
center left